[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tout le monde
c'est difficile de le dernière balle et
mais les organisateurs ont fait 6 parce
que des fois on vous met le dernier à
parler parce que vous n'apprenez pas
vous laissons vous restez assis pour
prendre note comme ça vous apprenez de
tous ceux qui sont passés
mais
dira-t-on voisin qu'il n'y a pas de
hasard dans la vie
et il n'a pas bien entendu donc je veux
que tu le dises
alors il n'y a pas de hasard dans la vie
parce que justement lorsque nous étions
en loge il fallait nous donner l'ordre
de passage et finalement j'ai été tiré
au sort pour passer le dernier
donc j'ai rigolé pour dire que comme
j'apprends pas bien mais laissons on m'a
mis des ailiers parce que je vais
prendre note mais paradoxalement et
comme ya pas de hasard dans la vie ma
modeste présentation est un peu comme le
résumé de cette intervention et si vous
n'appelez dit sais pas je vais pas
continuer
alors moi je vais parler de ce nouveau
monde est possible
parce que de tous ceux qui ont parlé on
a retenu que nous sommes dans le monde
des possibles et eve dans le monde des
possibles
ça commence par quelque chose de très
important pour moi
dans le crâne
j'ai écouté les sept intervenants et mon
introduction
tombe à propos
je n'ai pas la prétention et je suis pas
capable de faire le résumé de chacune de
vos interventions
mais j'ai dit pour moi au commencement
c'est à la pensée tout commence dans le
cloud
tout commence dans la tête et je veux
partager avec vous une petite histoire
que beaucoup de vous connaissent très
bien c'est l'histoire qui est racontée
dans un livre très s'il est un livre qui
est vraiment un des
mega mega best-seller qui est acheté et
qui est payée qui est distribuée qui au
fait dans le monde la bible
alors mon intervention s'est pas de
convaincre les uns les autres délits
toujours la bible ou de croire ce qui
est mentionné dans la bible
mais il ya une histoire dans ce livre
célèbre qui m'a marqué et que je veux
prendre pour illustrer mon propos
d'introduction qui est dans le crâne
ce livre sérieux ce qu'en ligne ce livre
et puis par d éminents et reedy nous
parle de l'histoire de quelqu'un de très
important qui s'appellait jésus
et dans l'histoire de ce monsieur il est
fait mention de ce qu'il est parti un
peu trop tôt parce que dans toutes les
civilisations du monde vous perdez un
enfant vous perdez un parent à 30 ans à
33 ans c'est une catastrophe je n'ai
jamais dit que quand on décède à 81 10
ans après une catastrophe
mais on ne peut pas accepter que
quelqu'un qui commence la vie de
monsieur puissent partir à cet âge et
dans ce livre on nous parle de jésus et
il paraît parce que je n'ai je n'ai pas
été très assidu de
confessions chrétiennes j'avais quand
même une petite discipline à respecter
celle de partie à la catéchèse quand
j'étais à l'école primaire j'avais été
quand même un garçon un peu turbulent
donc des fois je séchais les cours je
pensais que c'était pour ça qu'on
m'avait mis dernier intervenant est
l'histoire de ce monsieur nous dit que
il entretenait ce qui marchait avec lui
et ceux qui croyaient en lui et il est
10e à un moment donné ils vont le
sacrifier et quand il va être sacrifiée
tous ceux qui vont mettre sa confiance
en lui et qu'ils vont tous ceux qui vont
écouter les conseils qui va donner vont
gagner d'abord une liberté dans l'esprit
mais vont avoir quelque chose qui va
être très fort qu'on appelait la fois et
je suis vite allé regarder ce qu'on
appelait ce que ce qui était la
définition de la foi mais je me suis
attardé sur ce que la bible mais m'a dit
de la fois la ferme assurance des choses
qu'on espère et la démonstration de
celles qu'on ne voit pas
et donc ce monsieur jésus a dit à ses
adeptes que ils vont le crucifié et dans
la vie du monsieur ils ont effectivement
pris un matin et on l'envoyait à un
endroit à la sortie de jérusalem un
endroit qui s'appellait calcutta et j'ai
regardé la définition des quotas et j'ai
vu que la définition de golgotha c'est
le lieu du crade et dans l'histoire de
ce monsieur la définition de golgotha
nous enseigner que le lieu du crâne et
est un endroit très élevé de la ville de
jérusalem et cet endroit très élevé
c'est là bas que je suis devait être
crucifié mais là pas quand il sera prêt
si fier si vous mettez votre foi en lui
vous allez atteindre ou bien vous allez
avoir les choses et n'espérez vous allez
voir la démonstration des choses que
vous ne voyez pas
effectivement l'histoire s'est produite
comme ça et jésus a été crucifié à un
endroit très élevé de jérusalem il
s'appelait bogota
mais quand je reviens à la vue de nous
tous ici l'endroit le plus élevé de
notre corps c'est le crâne
le lieu du crâne mais dans mon crâne
et je me suis aperçu que cette histoire
nous donner une explication de quelque
chose de très important qui était le
commencement de tout ce qui a été dit
depuis les sept intervenants au
commencement commence
dans le crâne au commencement c'est à la
pensée vous devenez ce que vous voulez
devenir il n'y a rien d'impossible à
ceux qui croient tout est possible à
celui qu'il croit moi je crois qu'on va
se revoir et puis on va se serrer les
mains parce que vous allez réussi à
faire part au moment où on vous a dit
que vous n'allez pas avoir de la
motricité au niveau de vos membres nous
sommes tous témoins que vous avez de la
motricité d'un moment et aujourd'hui
vous êtes en train de nous écouter vous
êtes entrain de m'écouter vous avez
écouté tous les intervenants qui vous
ont dit que ça commence dans le car
parce que le vrai sujet des jeunes mais
aussi de nous tous c'est qu'on ne
travaille pas au commencement c'est
qu'on ne travaille pas c'est que le
principal moi aussi j'avais été un
garçon brillant à l'école et dans mon
histoire j'étais dans un petit village
où chaque année en fin de chaque mois on
faisait le classement et vous êtes
aligné cps jusqu'au cm2 et quand on doit
prendre la place de ce2 vous vous placez
et puis un des premiers
émois on disait même pas mon nom je
commençais à partie on dire tout net à
plat ça va quitter a peiné et il y avait
cette confiance
mais il y avait aussi cette
prédisposition à ce que les choses
marchent pour moi
hélas au cm2 j'ai échoué au cp
la deuxième fois j'ai joué encore à la
36e j'ai réalisé déjà tout petit qu'il
faut se calmer et il faut réchauffer
changer les choses mais ça n'a pas trop
bougé parce que j'ai continué et je suis
arrivé en 3e je n'ai pas eu le ppc j'ai
fait les réglages
j'ai eu le bac et j'ai passé je je je
continue mais j'étais le président du
bureau des étudiants de mon école
j'étais un des meilleurs élèves en place
des bts toute la classe de bts sauf deux
personnes une fille qui a pas continuer
parce qu'elle est enceinte et moi
mais vous pouvez vous renseigner de ma
génération aline steak j'ai été le
premier à être appelé dans une société
qui s'appellait lsl de loteny ou est
commercial dans ma vie je n'ai jamais
fait j'ai l'honneur de demandes et de
l'emploi
et depuis que je suis rentré dans ma
carrière professionnelle
tout a commencé à marcher jusqu'à
aujourd'hui pour vous dire que ça
commence dans le crâne mais parce que
nous sommes aussi dans un nouveau monde
nous sommes dans un nouveau monde où il
ya une nouvelle génération qui doit
comprendre qu'il faut fixer tout dans le
crâne pour avancer il faut que nous
soyons de cette génération là qui
n'avons peur de rien nous avons chacun
vécu des situations je veux pas
continuer d aix ans parce que mes
prédécesseurs ont déjà tout dit mais je
vais vous parler de ce nouveau monde il
faut changer les paradigmes de ce
nouveau monde où il faut maintenant
fonctionner parce que rien n'est
impossible à celui qu'il croit et que
tout est possible c'est quoi ce nouveau
monde
mais ce nouveau monde ou en afrique où
toutes les études où tous les
commentaires ou tous les sujets disent
que c'est la destination du succès mais
ce nouveau monde où on nous dit
maintenant que même si vous êtes vous
avez été le dernier de la place vous
pouvez le premier d'une génération
mais ce nouveau monde qui aussi est en
train de dessiner cette nouvelle est
mais tout dépend de comment vous
comprenez les mois je comprends cette
nouvelle et comme l'est l'ambiance le
temps nous sommes dans ce nouveau temps
dans ce nouveau moment où tout est
effectivement possible où chacun de nous
a besoin d'avoir une nouvelle culture je
bouscule des fois des amis vous l'a dit
tu as lu combien de livres ce mois des
cadres des hauts cadres qui reste la
méthode on a fait des nids moi je suis
même pas lire mais je me débrouille pour
li de livres ou un neuf et demi par mois
alors que j'ai des occupations terrible
parce que notre génération qui doit
prendre la relève qui doit prendre les
commandes qui doit changer
la façon de faire qui doit mener
l'afrique est la destination du
développement doit comprendre que si
tant que vous n'êtes pas cultiver vous
ne savez rien
mais nous sommes aussi dans cette
nouvelle aire géographique qui l afrique
qui finalement est la convoitise du
monde entier parce que c'est ici que se
trouve la description
c'est ainsi que se trouvent les
technologies chaque fois que la
technologie est venu en afrique les
africains utiliser sans modération
parce qu'on a cette faculté
divine de transcender quand on a touché
à la technologie mais en même temps on
est dans cette nouvelle et
qui est cette nouvelle époque
cette nouvelle époque où on n'a plus de
complexe où allait nous partons dans le
monde entier nous sommes au perchoir et
192 pays du monde nous écoute
et partagent notre affi et des x s'élève
applaudir un témoignage que ce petit
africain à du contenu nous sommes dans
une période où les seuls les hommes les
femmes africaines africaine
change le cours de l'histoire du monde
nous sommes dans cette période où il n'y
a pas de complexe c'est cette période là
qui est
finalement la période qui nous a
convoqué ici ou qui nous a invités ici
cette nouvelle ère où une infime partie
aussi de la population se met à l'écart
pour distrait de son temps pour
comprendre ou pour bénéficier
de certains partagent mais en même temps
que nous sommes dans cette nouvelle est
mangée en vidéo conclu avec
le point suivant
ton voisin
ta voisine
est aujourd'hui à côté de toi parce
qu'il était écrit depuis des années
lumière que aujourd'hui 22 vous deviez
vos assurances en savez le vrai problème
de notre génération de notre territoire
de notre pays de notre continent c'est
que on s'est un peu démarqué de la
culture quand vous prenez la période de
nos devanciers on a définitivement
arrêté d'avoir des modèles on a
définitivement arrêté d'avoir des
personnes à qui on veut rassembler des
fois nous a montré des stéréotypes à la
télévision et on veut nous forcer à
ressembler à ces personnes je veux te
dis que la personne à qui tu dois
rassembler c'est celle ci je vais te
donner son descriptif la personne à qui
tu dois ressembler elle est une personne
intelligente une brave personne et elle
est dans ce pays je vais te donner tout
son nom
je suis venu cet après midi de donner le
nom de la personnalité dans notre pays
que tu dois regarder et tu dois suivre
vous devenir celui que tu dois devenir
et cette personnalité est là et non et
j'ai pris le temps avant d'arriver de
noter le nom de cette personne vous ne
pouvez vous pouvez ne pas être d'accord
avec le nom de cette personne mais je
veux que vous acceptez que à partir
d'aujourd'hui il faut marcher comme la
personne que je vais vous donner c'est
une personne qui est forte c'est une
personne qui ne recule devant rien c'est
une personne des vents qui rien ne
résiste
et cette personne
c'est toi
cette personne c'est toi c'est moi
tu ne peux pas devenir
meilleur que la même personne que tu es
donc au commencement c'est dans ton
crâne c'est dans ta tête des signes la
meilleure personne que tu veux devenir
et commence à marcher comme cette
personne nous sommes dans le temps des
possibles et je voudrais pour conclure
que chacun se lève pour applaudir le
même homme qui les réveille le meilleur
homme qui emploie applaudissent mais on
garde toi et tu reçois veut pas se voir
avec dans le crâne que le maire de la
génération c toi allait tuer le maire de
la génération pas tout tu es le maire de
cette génération à partir d'aujourd'hui
comme marc cherrey marché on dit que
vous êtes le meilleur de cette
génération que le maire de cette
nouvelle ère merci pour votre attention
et que tu es béni ce lapin deux roues
merci à tmx
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]